foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is James page at the ftth
conference in Madrid I've been joined by
a telephonicas CT IO Enrique Blanco
Enrique thank you for joining us
um big topics being spoken about here at
the conference particularly thinking
about the ability of Europe to get full
fiber to everybody everywhere what's
your view on where we are and and how
we're doing in that aim so uh excellent
question so Fiverr and the ftth
technology it is it is mandatory trying
to digitize the societies when we are
operating the only kind of firm and that
you have a society that it is
fully detected if you are offering your
customer the quality and the only way
trying to offer quality is with the ftth
so we we knows that and we are starting
28 trying to deploy eftta to all our
customers and today we are just making
extraordinary movements trying to work
and did that up to the 80 85 percent of
the population in our societies when we
operate discovered by ftth and this is
something that we learn and even in the
non-dance areas we just find some levels
sign formulas trying to guarantee that
all the capex Necessities finally will
be covered covering non-dance and rural
areas so our mindset is only with ftdh
plus 5G Julie can put the Societies in
the goal that they really need trying to
to
enjoy all the capabilities that the the
the the different application and
different Services can offer so this is
because we have in the past the decision
in 28 trying to do it and this is
because today in Spain so in the next
year we will be switching off all the
copper in Spain this is an extraordinary
message so all the customers of
telephone in kindness plan they will be
used in ftth this is an example we are
doing something similar in Brazil so we
are just defining fiber costs helping us
trying to push and to growth in
footprint of ftth so ftth it is
mandatory okay so it will copper off in
Spain and full fiber by 2028 in sort of
getting to rural regions too that's it's
a capital and sort of financially
difficult thing to do how how are you
managing to do that in 2024 so we will
be switching off all the customer with
copper in Spain and this is something
that is a long history that we are
starting 28.
this is our commitment
and it is covered in all areas
getting all the agreement that we need
creating the Fiverr calls that we need
trying to cover at that time to offer
the right coverage in the older rural
orders and this is something that we are
doing in Spain and that we are doing the
same strategy in all the countries when
we are operating the only way to
warranty
that we are serving our societies it is
combining ftth plus 5G
okay so you're confident about doing
that you must feel like the right
regulations are in in place to do that
you've been helped by that is there
anything you think needs to happen to
make that to make sure that happens or
to make that easier for telephonica to
achieve that so Eber gandry has a
different regulation and and it's quite
different in in Germany when we are just
building our fiber coogiji for this
trying to cover so in the in the small
municipalities quite different in Spain
when we had been working with all the we
are managing all the different companies
that we have been covering so and we are
getting some agreement with them trying
to guarantee that all the customers can
enjoy with mtth so quite different in in
Brazil who it is just a continent when
we just start covering the main cities
and we are just defining a fiber
Coatesville Brazil which is uh
um building a wholesale Market trying to
guarantee that the velocity of the ftth
covers so different in countries
different Necessities different
Regulators but same idea
Faber and ftth it is the solution for
the 80 of the total traffic that a
customer it is managing in his Digital
Life
okay well thank you for explaining that
um you know and we're here talking about
ftth but a month ago or so I think it
was now out uh on the other side of
Spain we were at Mobile World Congress
and there telephonica launched the open
Gateway initiative what's the role of
fiber in there it's not just about
mobile is it so it is it's not about
technology it is about customer
performance if you analyze a customer in
the day by day here's just roughly 80
Wi-Fi
20 mobile
so the average traffic of a customer
with ftth it is up to 500 gigabytes per
month if you're analyze in a mobile
customer it is 12 to 15 it is this means
that up to the 80 percent of the total
traffic and the customer it is managed
by the Wi-Fi who it is
supported by the fixed technology and in
the case of telefonica this is an ftdh
connection
there are a lot of initiatives a lot of
opportunities how we can build the same
concept that it is defined for the open
gate what this means how we can Define
Services very easy simple to upify
and how we can build Services of
warranted Quality quality on demand
in the fix itself and telefonica because
we have all all the the the development
capabilities in home as a computer
approach and so on we are just including
in camera
uh specific services that will be
managed in the same way that the
services Amplified in the mobile
offering to the customer the possibility
to for instance enjoy a specific quality
on demand when he is just using the ftth
and the Wi-Fi approach let's imagine
you're at home you have a conference
relevant you have a service you have a
video capabilities you have a gaming and
you are asking to warranty it in the
next two hours three hours four hours
so a quality specific quality in terms
of throughput latest and so on and you
will be at home you will be using Wi-Fi
so we are just including this concept in
the ftth and we can do it because we
have the platform that can be supported
and we have all the technology and all
the software and the home as a computer
concept for our customers this means
that
new services with the quality on demand
guaranteed will be supported by the ftth
and Wi-Fi and we are ready to do it and
we're including in camera
so this kind of comes with the services
it's extremely relevant it is and it's
an extremely exciting future that you're
painting so um thank you uh so much
America for coming and explaining some
of that to us thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]